the palms is back property leaders
announcing today it will reopen under
new ownership april 27th that's right
the hotel casino has been closed for
about two years now but today we got to
tour the inside to see firsthand what
guests can expect when the doors open
again thanks for choosing the palms a
new chapter is about to begin for palms
casino resort construction crews are up
against the clock to make everything
ready for the launch on april 27th this
time under new owners we're going to
celebrate
in the culture of our we are the first
native american owned and operated
resort in las vegas the san manuel
gaming and hospitality authority
purchased the 766 room property off
flamingo and valley view boulevard from
station's casinos last year in 2020 the
pandemic shut down operations after
going through a 600 million dollar
renovation which general manager cynthia
kaiser hopes will help attract the
crowds we are completely redoing our
sportsbook it's going to be a really
premium viewing experience the return of
scotch 80 prime and mabel's barbecue
also on the list of dining and
entertainment and the properties movie
theater is getting a new stadium seating
and technology johnny brendan hired
local graffiti artists to redo
all of the theater quarters and then
another artist to redo the floors the
palms will open right as las vegas
welcomes the nfl draft kaiser says the
palms is beefing up staff hiring about a
hundred new employees and plans to
create a neighborhood vibe inside the
resort are on track thanks to the former
staff now back on duty we've had over we
believe almost 50 percent of our team
are going to be returning palms
employees and we are just
really really excited about that
well kaiser also telling us that the
first reservation happened this morning
now the ghost bar expected to open
shortly after the property does and the
garage parking will be free